foreign
[Applause]
poured into Toshiba Plaza after the
night's historic win players popped and
poured bottles of champagne in the
locker room here's Mark Stone he's
hoisting up the cup under champagne
showers and well that cup had quite a
night and morning it turns out yeah
that's pretty normal for the Stanley Cup
the Stanley Cup has quite the history as
we know Lorna Grady is live outside
Caesar's Palace where the team was
partying through the night into the
morning possibly even now with Lord
Stanley's cup in tow Lauren good morning
yeah the energy is still
still heading by we got some honking
horns some people waving their vgk gear
out the windows at us so that's a fun
time but yes the team was spotted out at
Omnia nightclub with the cup as well
we're kind of chasing the cup this
morning the proverbial chasing the cup
uh to see how they went there you can
see in the video there people are
cheering waving their vgk flag snapping
photos of the coveted cup you know it
was not just the team celebrating people
continue the party over at Circus
Stadium swim and the Fremont Street
Experience as well
we were born here we we bought our own
players here
everything's different and we we just
won and we deserve it
other fans really say they knew vgk
would win the cup describing the game as
non-stop so once again from all of us
here at 8 news congratulations to the
Vegas golden knights live out here by
Las Vegas Boulevard and Flamingo Road
laurina Grady 8 news now back to you
guys what a night we should be that's
the way it's supposed to be with the
gold Stanley Cup I think so now that
they drink out of the cup that's the
photo always that that always happens
people eat cereal out of the Stanley Cup
oh they wash it in between well I can't
guarantee that Lauren thank you so much